alright hello everybody and welcome back
to Android design in action my name is
Roman Nurik and wit me here today is
Adam Koch and they go through Oh so
today we're going to be talking about
shopping list apps and the contextual
action bar and Before we jump in I just
want to remind everybody what the show
is all about so on Android design in
action we take a look at apps that have
been previously reviewed on the App
clinic which is on Fridays and we take a
look at how we can improve some of the
screens some of the visual designs in
the screens of those abs and then more
recently we've been diving into specific
topics for example a few weeks ago we
did responsive design meaning designing
for tablets and phones and basically any
any of any screen size on a spectrum of
devices and today like I said we're
going to be talking about the contextual
action bar so let's jump in with the
very first step that will look at which
was done last week we reviewed last week
on the App clinic and that app is
grocery IQ so Before we jump into the
redesign let's talk about what this app
does and so this app basically lets you
manage a number of different lists or
shopping lists so let's say you have you
know a favorite bakery nearby or
favorite supermarket nearby and you know
that they sell certain products so we
can do is you can actually create a
shopping list and create or add items to
your list that are broken up by the
different stores in which you would buy
them so the bakery may have breads and
cereals and things like that and the
grocery store supermarket may have other
things so one of the key differences
between this app and other shopping list
apps is the ability to kind of break
things up in that way also it lets you
let's just zoom into the screens here it
lets you look at some coupons for
different I guess for different products
that you may want to buy may be
contextually relevant or not it lets you
store favorites lets you do a lot of
different
things so it's basically a shopping list
that lets you kind of neatly categorize
your different items and lets you also
look at coupons as well Before we jump
in have you guys used this app at all or
give any other thoughts on on the
initial initial background on the scent
nope no not really actually um I did try
it a little while back and unfortunately
for me when I see the design looked kind
of dated like this I usually go and just
sort of uninstall it immediately so I
didn't get to sort of try it out too
much unfortunately yeah in this app is
to be fair I mean like it's it's using
some of the older patterns some of the
gingerbread styling with the tabs
actually you know about a year or so ago
they'd probably or maybe two years ago
those would be perfectly normal tabs and
they're actually using the correct
guidelines for the for the icons and so
on and so forth for tabs but it's really
just kind of dating that's exactly how I
put it and of course the the menu button
yeah I don't know Shane down the bona
that the other the guys from the app
clinic mentioned as well yeah the legacy
menu button is something that should
really just go away and we have we have
a solution for that anyway but yeah and
the other the other issue here is that
it's using some of the kind of the
gradients that you'd find on other
platforms kind of those stark gradients
and also just these kind of one pixel
tech shadows this is something we
haven't really talked about before in
the show but another thing that
developers do a lot of side with you
know sign up from gradients and things
like that is adding these tiny little
shadows to kind of give a sense of depth
to your text and an Android do you mean
that's it's perfectly fine to do you can
you can do it in a lot of cases but
oftentimes it's done without real
thought as to why you know is there is
there a reason for doing this and I
think in this case it works fairly well
because it's very subtle but if you were
to move over to the kind of the holo
visual styling the Android the new
modern Android UI look and feel and
should try to avoid kind of things like
like that kind of those things that add
a subtle sense of depth it's almost
unnecessary but again it's totally fine
if the rest of your visual design
matches with that
and the other thing that we like to
point out is you know right facing
carrots actually on this screen touching
the list items here doesn't really do
anything and actually there's nothing
but to get into the details you actually
have to touch this the secondary action
or the secondary touch area on the list
item and then to check the item you just
touch this checkbox so some of these
things you know make sense some of them
not so much so we wanted to kind of
rethink how you could approach the
screen in this app in general so let's
jump into the redesign screen hopefully
this gets one hundred percent okay so
let's jump into the redesign screen so
as we always do we've added a proper
action bar we've added some iconography
some branding at the top left we added a
single check out action button and check
out is is a you'll notice back here
check out is something that you know
after you check the items that you've
purchased you can press check out and it
moves those items into your history so
that then you know the next time you're
shopping or such you can just bring
things into your list directly from your
history so it's kind of a neat neat
little feature and we decided to move
that isn't as a primary action the
action bar we also added spinner
navigation at the top so that it will
show details on that in a second but
basically lets you switch between the
different stores and you'll see later
lets you manage stores and things like
that as well and then for you know for
the actual list itself we've presented a
you know the same old list but to
actually jump into the details you just
touch once on on the text here and just
as before you can check the box the left
to the market is complete but it doesn't
actually move it into a completely
separate area once it's checked it stays
put which is probably a more safer
interaction a more consistent
interaction
the other thing I should mention is that
we've also brought up coupons this is
one thing I wanted to talk about and it
seems like coupons in this app but i
think the developer is coupons com seems
like coupons are fairly important part
of either the business model or you know
it may be its revenue driving I don't
really know but coupons seemed fairly
important but they weren't immediately
visible so one way in which we try to
bring that out more is to make it more
contextually relevant so if there's a
coupon for one of the items in your in
your list let's say nearby I got a store
nearby there's a coupon for it it'll
show up as a secondary action here with
the number of coupons found and then
touching that takes you to the coupon
details screen and we also decided that
you know why not make coupons a
secondary section at the bottom right
either you know let's say I have no list
items I have nothing on my shopping list
why not just show coupons hey you know I
forgot to get soup the the other week
and there's a coupon for soup so let me
just you know pop that into my shopping
list but also if you do have lots of
shopping list items then you're probably
not so much worried about other products
you probably want to just get rid of
those products and buy those you know
and not worry about anything else and so
coupons moves all the way to the bottom
of that and then we use a different
visual indicator this kind of almost fo
torn edge and this is borderline
skeuomorphic but it doesn't really
matter it's kind of the second the
secondary part of the screen that shows
you that this is clearly a different
part of the app and a different set of
items so it's a clear visual delineation
and then we've also used kind of this
this blue accent color throughout to
indicate that this is a coupon kind of
like on google com you see the ads the
text ads in search results on a yellow
background this would be kind of similar
so you present a visual theme throughout
that says hey blue is advertising or
blue is
ponds and green is your stuff so it's
kind of one of one of the ways to think
about that and the last thing i want to
point on this screen before if you guys
want to chime in is this bar at the top
and this is something that adam and i
talked about beforehand and nick is well
I believe it is really like how do you
present adding items or searching for
stuff and in this case searching and
adding is really part of the same flow
and we decided to make it kind of a
first class citizen rather than an
action button we've put it in line at
the very top of the list so yeah so
that's that's all i wanted to mention
Adam remember you had thoughts on on
search and add need to talk about some
alternatives or yeah I guess one thing I
wanted to sort of talk about was um you
know you can always have an action item
but if the if the action is really
important you can put it in line like
Roman has shown here but I guess if you
did want to you could move that sort of
a door search box back into the action
bar is an action item and maybe trigger
the sort of contextual search that shows
actually directly in the action bar
itself so you know that's just an
alternative you know totally up to the
designer of the app as to how they
actually want to implement this yeah
almost kind of like like an expanding
search food but maybe it's an expanding
add view yep an interesting approach
yeah and in some of the later and one of
the later apps Nick will talk about all
some similar ways in which we approach
this in out of milk but anyway let's
move on to the next screen for the
interest of time so the next screen
again since this is about the contextual
action bar this is just briefly showing
that you know let's say I wanted to
immediately you know take action on
three or four of those items I can just
long press to start selection and that
pops up the contextual action bar at the
top and then keep single touching
different items in my list to add or
remove from the selection and then take
action on that entire selection so in
this case I've selected hoegaarden and
McAllen I hopefully it's spelled McAllen
right hoegaarden McAllen and then let's
say I've gone ahead and bought those
items at the store I can just select
both and press mark purchased two to
take action immediately on those two
items
in the next in the next screen this is
an example of that drop down and this is
kind of interesting this is something
that we we took a few liberties with a
spinner I guess drop-down / spinner
navigation usually you just see you know
the items which you're switching between
right so in a normal case you can see
you know grocery store bakery or any
store meaning like all of the above but
in this case since I thought that since
since this is like the single place
where users see their list of stores
this is like the most the most visible
place in the app where they see their
list of stores let's make it easy to to
also then take action on those little
that list so then maybe add a store to
that list right from here and this is
something that Ian mentioned last week
on the App clinic you know it's it's a
missed opportunity if you see a list of
things and you know you want to add one
but you then can't figure out how to do
it so this way it makes it very obvious
it's a slight deviation from the
standard pattern but you know I
personally feel that it's it's a fairly
fairly reasonable deviation and then the
other thing is that there's also
favorites and history and to navigate to
those items and again there's still
lists of tasks really at the end of the
day you can jump into favorites in
history right from here with this kind
of separate section so any any
criticisms or thoughts or alternatives
but why don't we throw it over to to me
quickly yeah yeah for me like I'm
looking at the original designer just
kind of screen gingerbread to me it
always a I think the Refresh that you've
given it makes it look much more modern
much more home on my online device
running jelly bean or whatever the
latest OS everyone is running and also
it just it feels easier to use because
the standard iconography understand the
controls from a modern palette just a
very familiar to me so I think this is a
really lovely redesign yeah and thank
you and I one other things that we
should probably talk about at the end is
the difference between selection and
checkboxes and there's lots of different
ways you can go about this and I think
Nikki tried an alternative
in out of milk but we should definitely
talk about at the very end afraid of
some time since that's something that
like that specifically with task list
apps or list apps that can you know be
confusing in some cases so the last
screen that we have here is with editing
a store and then we'll jump over to Adam
milk so when editing a story of the
option to edit the store name and then
if you'll notice here you can add or
reorder aisles as well as hi dials but
it seems like in this case this is
really kind of like a sub dashboard
pattern rather than giving you the
content immediately the list of aisles
it just gives you the options in which
you can take on the on that list so
rather than doing that we felt that it
would be just a better user experience
to show everything at once so you can
immediately edit the name as well as
reorder and hide aisles so and yet we're
also using this done discard pattern at
the very top so rather than seeing like
a save button or anything like that we
see very clear options to either cancel
what we just did or save by pressing the
done button and then here you'll notice
that we use these subtle drag handles to
allow you to reorder items and then the
entire the rest of the list item the
rest of that touch area is a single
touch target to show or hide so touching
it basically toggles its visibility and
you'll notice that there isn't a
separator between this visibility marker
and the rest of the list item and that's
to indicate that it's a single touch
target not two separate targets and then
obviously you can you can add an aisle
by pressing the plus button there and of
course I mean if you long touch maybe
there should be you know contextual
action bar there as well haven't really
mucked it up but yeah so anyway parting
thoughts for a grocery IQ guys I think
the direct manipulation is much better
than having to go through each level I
think the same way you surface coupons
up to a high level it's you know makes
it easier to use if you don't have to
pogo stick as they say in and out of
different screens camp yeah I also like
that coupons tear off that you have at
the bottom there just because as you say
it's probably important to their
business the company itself is called
coupons
but also like it sort of dynamically
grows and shrinks based on what the real
content is on that particular screen so
I think it's a nice way of showing
everything at one screen yeah the other
thing is that you know if you have no
empty or if you have a empty list if you
have no items in that list then I mean
naturally you think oh let's just show
no items in this list text and that's it
right so the user opens up the app and
they immediately see an empty list and
so showing coupons is another way of
presenting more useful information
without having to fill the space with
like useless stuff so and likewise if
the list is really really long those
coupons aren't going to get directly in
your way they get pushed down off the
screen and the content is still going to
be seen there at the front and I mean
worst case if you find that users don't
like interact with coupons as much
because of that then you can always have
like a an overflow item or something
else in the action bar or something that
leads you to that screen so let's jump
into out of milk how much time we have a
good all right okay so let's jump into a
de milk Nick do you want to talk about
out of milk yeah absolutely sir auto
milk is a kind of a to-do list type
application but very focused on shopping
list so when you come in it gives you
free pretty that really made my list
elections like a shopping list it's do
list and something else I forget so it's
quite focused on that and it's a slight
kind of twist on the regulator to this
it's kind of got some extra
functionality in there so you can see he
in the action bar you have the ability
to use a barcode scanner which is kind
of cool so you can add items to it and
you also have the option to add some
metadata around each of the items in
your list so if you example you can see
milk here you can give it a price and
then you can get a summary of the total
price remaining in your basket of goods
to pick up at the bottom so yeah I've
dived in flow you you come in on a
dashboard pattern I've dived into one of
the main screens like managing like
viewing a list and you have this kind of
spin and navigation for flip flitting
between the two I think when I look at
the screen the first thing and that
stands out to me is that
and despite the fact they're using an
action bar and have an overflow button
there they also have the the button of
shame as we're pulling at the emulated
and menu button down at the bottom so
this is kind of perplexing to me that
they kind of have both especially
because the emulated button doesn't
really do anything down the bottom
they're just setting a target SDK 10 I
believe even though they're providing
styles and using an action bar shut up I
believed to have an action bar our force
exporter there's a few issues as well
and if you take a look at their action
bar that and I think to speak to some of
the Pope points of Romans made in the
past about if you're going to use an
action bar kind of really try and follow
the standard patterns to it and don't
kind of like DJ around away from it and
so first up with the action bar say and
the overflow button is kind of like too
heavy style if you look at the normal
I'm action bars that the overflow is
slightly less prominent it's about a
fifty percent opacity in order to
de-emphasize the kind of the secondary
tasks and compared to the primary
actions and also some of the icons don't
really have the holo styling and spiller
spiller isn't really attached to the
shopping list it's kind of like orphaned
over across to the side and which is
especially bad in tablets when you're in
a landscape in a tablet it's kind of you
know three-quarters the screen away from
the thing it's supposed to be marking up
as being clickable and there's then some
de limiters between the icons and and on
top of that there's also a fair amount
of skeuomorphic style and kind of like
just really like non hanno non native
platforms styling in the application any
other thoughts on the option me you guys
before we dive into what we've done with
it it's like they've kind of gone
halfway with the skeuomorphic thing but
not all the way which is almost worse
than just getting all the way if you ask
me yeah yeah it's kind of tough I think
you guys are you guys are right that
it's like a bit too skeuomorphic but at
the same time you're like I feel like
you know following the interactions to
me personally I mean following the
interactions is first and foremost and
to me that the greater issue here I
think is with kind of the the extra
overflow or the legacy menu button
things like that just fundamentally
break some of the the expectations that
users have
but yeah I do agree that the
skeuomorphism is like somewhere there's
a spectrum right there's like pure like
minimalism and then like pure
skeuomorphism or you know kind of
realism whatever and I feel like they
chose a some you know a place on that
spectrum that's a little further to the
right before we go into the redesign
just a few ways on the interaction
design here so the way the app currently
works if you single tap on an item in
the list hit em pops up and of old salt
quick action bar which lets you do
things like edited all marketers done
for example and and if you long press on
an item here then puts a score for it
and move it to the bottom like denying
that it's done so you kind of have these
two levels of that says like an item the
list then you can have it scored through
or then you can actually delete it to
totally remove it so and there's many
permutations of state which night and
convene and because of this if you
disclose the overflow menu I don't think
we've got a screenshot of it here but if
you do there is a plethora of options
and you actually have to scroll it on a
Galaxy Nexus it's that many overflow
options which I found and to be a bit of
bit could have overloaded me and yeah
and using I mean this is kind of the
against the the concept of direct
manipulation which is one of the direct
I guess the design principles and a
design guide you know items should be
manipulable you should be able to touch
them to interact with them rather than
choosing actions somewhere else to do
things like trigger selection or like
select all deselect all anything like
that should really be more contextual
and in general I mean if you look at
just for a long press think that's
particularly egregious in this case
where you know long press we've tried to
standardize on what long press means and
really it means selection it trigger it
triggers selection and then potentially
you know showing actions on your
selection I'm so using it for anything
else like you know marking an item is
complete it's kind of
beyond what the standards are and it's
just another thing that users have to
learn one other thing that I guess we
use for long presses when you long press
on an action button when on an icon only
button it shows your little tool tip but
that's kind of a secondary use for it
it's not as a as important to use a
selection so in the Nick I just wanted
to mention that I've been showing your
your redesign already by accident so
unfortunately we don't have a big reveal
but but go ahead and jump it okay yep so
if we do take a look at the redesign
that you've been looking at for all this
time then we can see and we've applied
some holo styling to it so we've used
some familiar language visual language
in the application to make it a bit
easier to see is actually quite
interesting that Roman and I did our
redesigns in isolation and refused and
quite similar metaphors like the drag
handles and so on and throughout but I
guess that's why their standard right
mmm but then the other thing I did we
mention is there's some really cool
information and court actions you can do
it buried in the overflow menu on the
original such as you have to share this
list with someone else or send it to you
know using the normal Android sharing
with intense which is kind of lost in
all the noise in the overflow menu I
thought so one of the main things like
apart from applying holo styling to the
look and feel is I've kind of promoted
and add to being this permanent inline
action similar two and Romo did with the
search and add so you have this this bar
there which is which breaks out of the
standard rhythm of the rest of the page
in order to make it more prominent and
I've also broken down the the user
microphone or the bar code as kind of
sub actions of adding their different
kind of ways of adding an item to your
list so they kind of like belong put
together having separate action items
and so yeah so by bringing add into the
page itself and it's given me some room
in the action bar to promote some of the
you know
and unique and very very cool
functionality of this and this
application office and then tuck and the
the less use and much smaller set of
alternative actions under yoga flow so
we've also changed up the interaction a
little bit here as well you can see I've
placed some checkboxes next to the items
and which allow you to go into a
selection mode and so I've actually kind
of flipped the concept or change the
concept a little bit and got rid of the
idea of like a a semi kind of strict
strike fruit done state and just gone
straight to a dismiss state so i decided
to employees to kind of the swipe to
dismiss pattern that we're seeing
gaining gaining traction these days and
as the way to mark items off so this is
speaking to romans point about direct
manipulation of your data being much
more satisfying so what you can actually
do yeah okay it's really like swipe to
complete rather than swipe to delete i
wrote took the delete here but it's like
swipe to mark is completed basically
right yeah cool so this is a bit of a
change to the pattern so i guess in the
old way you would long press it be
struck true so it's still be able to get
it back quickly so it's a way to give
you that kind of safety net that way to
easily recover any data that you've kind
of marks complete and we've also used a
new pattern and emerging pattern of
thief and i'm undo so when you swipe way
an item to say it's done we actually for
a temporarily show this undo option in
line where it was the idea here being
that you can until you interact with the
screen again this will stay there so you
gives you this chance to say oh actually
I you know I check the wrong item
whatever and but in the minute you start
scrolling or touching another writer and
the idea is that this will kind of close
up and you know the listing so next one
the quick return you want to talk about
that yeah absolutely and so this is to
go with the idea that we've made add
this week and I prominent item but um we
wanted to kind of cope with the case
that you know you might be having too
many kind of layers of items at the top
you have an action bar sometimes might
have tabs if you have an inline kind of
prominent action you end up running out
of room especially if you in say
landscape view where you have less
vertical space so I'm using here a
pattern which we've been dubbing quick
return which earned
I think is really really cool way to
kind of handle that problem so the idea
here is if you had a lot of items so
here I'm making lasagna and I got a lot
of items in my list and it I let me use
it as a scroll away the the Add button
this kind of had the horizontal bar will
scroll out of you and but the minute
they start kind of like dragging back
down it'll jump right back in and kind
of be this flirting item so what this
really does it kind of lets you maximize
the amount of space you have to play
with in the screen and show you know
show the items on the list so if you're
searching through the list looking for a
particular item to check off then it
gives you the maximum space to present
that but it makes adding a new item like
super simple and always and very
convenient to do this is similar to
looking much of Google now and and also
Google Plus as this right so Google Plus
if you're in the stream and you scroll
you know if you scroll down the buttons
that let you post to the stream scroll
off but then as soon as you start kind
of slowly inching inching up again it
pops those back in yeah that's the idea
so should we move on to contextual
actions yeah so the next time next next
thing we'll just cover here so in the
old application if you touch them nice
and you get this quick bar which let you
perform a number of actions upon a
single item and so that new way of doing
this really is using the contextual
action bar so here if you long press or
I say and tap on the check mark you'll
go into this contextual selection mode
so here we selected one item and using
the contextual action bar you can and
edit or the second icon any action bar
there's you can you know move it to
another list or delete the item straight
from there and the power of using the
contextual action bar i believe is not
only this like you next very consistent
with a platform way of handling
selection but it's also great for
dealing with multi select so here you
can see the limiter which says one item
selected it's actually a drop-down so
right here I could dispose that and you
might get options to select all or in
this example here I've tapped another
and another item in the list and it's
let me do contextual action so here you
can see because I'm dealing with two
items select
rather than one and we've actually
refined the selection so we said that
edit might not be applicable to multiple
items and and it's refined it dances
using two actions here so it's a really
kind of very neat way of performing
quite powerful kind of selection actions
yeah so unless you're like a batch edit
mode or something where like you batch
apply a tag or something then yeah
removing that edit icon Mick sent cool
and just a fun to stick with the
metaphor we've been using of using the
swype so mark something is completed
before we keep it wet if you are
selecting multiple items at once you
could then still swipe across on one of
these items and it would mark each of
them is completed that's cool I've never
seen that done before but that looks
like it might work really really well
it's very cool just a fun idea to be
kind of called the hint that you can do
that by you know when the user selects
the actual contextual action item you
could have the animation play and have
the Unruh in place still and that way
they know next time they could probably
just go and swipe themselves I like that
it's cool yeah this might be one of
those cases we talked about the showcase
view last week where you know if it
isn't so completely apparent by a wats
on screen like a gesture you had to
perform I think it's okay to hint it the
first time the user sees it that you
could you know show some pie lamination
animation saying you know kids so
quarter to do this the marks I'm going
on so I think this it would be to agree
just to show on the first run and then
let the you know and teaches a dummy
mm-hmm I can work and also just wanted
to point out that that's a great thing
that you pointed out is that you know
showing an animation hint at a gesture
so for example when you have a tab or
tabs with a view pager when you switch
tabs you call like you know pager that
set current item but calling that it
actually slides the contents so it's a
subtle hint that you can actually then
you know throw your finger on this on
the glass and start swiping across the
different tabs so that's a toughy a good
way to to hint at a gestures to show an
animation that that replays the gesture
basically without the user interacting
cool all right so let's jump into a few
other examples of the contextual action
bar since we wanted to talk about it
before we before we jump into all the
details oh wow we're super low on time
so we're taught to fly through this
contextual action bar basically lets you
show multiple actions on a selection or
it enters a mode basically where you can
you can you know take action on
selections anybody else have anything to
add on and we're going okay you know
what rather than do that let's just fly
through some of these these are some
examples of apps that use it so the
gallery lets you take actions on
multiple photos gmail lets you take
action on multiple items and then this
is an open source example a Google i/o
app which basically lets you it shows a
contextual action bar for this master
detail flow on a tablet so if you select
multiple items even if you're looking at
one or a different one you can take
action items without even lookin at them
and this is another example of an app
called tasks by team tasks that lets you
take actions like indent or we run
indent I guess different items within a
task list all at once so Sam yeah
detection action bars I am you might
have guessed that we're huge fans of the
action bar because it's you know
familiar and very powerful and very
flexible and so using contextual action
bar lets you you know have the same
power of the action bar but to do this
contextual action so you can still do
things like have a split action bar so
gmail on phones for example as a
platform options which office you can do
an email so you can still use that speed
action pilot to offer up all those
different things so I'm a big fan of it
yeah definitely use it if you can and
believe actionbarsherlock also supports
the contextual action bar so you have to
worry about you know backwards
compatibility things like that anyway
let's let's fly through next week though
that's it for the content for the show
today actually I guess we have design
news in a bit next week we're going to
be doing a Google+ Hangout and we'd like
to invite you all to join so if you're
interested in talking to us live in this
on this show at the same time
if you wanted like ask us questions or
if you want to show some of you work by
screen sharing or if you just want to
rant about Android design please let us
know if you can join if you can make it
let us know in the comments on pretty
much anywhere and we'll invite you next
week maybe about 10 or 15 minutes before
the show airs and then we'll have a
30-minute hang out to discuss and we may
be announcing giveaways or anything that
so you may want to tune in and
definitely like I said let us know if
you can join but let's fly through
Android design news we don't have that
much Nikki want to talk about your live
redesign yeah this was a fine i think i
mentioned last week that i was a
visiting berlin for a dead fest event
and i've got on stage to do a lie that
free design so i was looking at a pretty
cool app actually to control the lights
in the building Runa which had an API
but it was kind of like thrown together
demo where and didn't really have and
the best and most modern Android UI so I
was live talking through some things we
could change while very talented
designer Marie pretty regularly and
mentioned on the show was using her
awesome illustrator skills to throw
together these design so this as you can
see the room just zoom down elm and 50s
are 25 minutes working managed to go to
pretty pretty cool-looking redesign
Erick and say yeah you can follow the QR
code to see a recording of that talk if
you interested yeah very well done i was
super fast she like works super fast and
illustrator it's crazy alright actually
wanted memory one more plug for her
she's just opened up an etsy shop so she
has these amazing paintings of android
so if you're a fan of them left an app
for android then and look it up on
google person finder etsy shop and buy a
droid all right um and i think that the
last news item is there's a blog post
recently that talks about the different
units used in android so dips
density-independent pixels also SP units
scale and pennant pixels if you're still
confused about the difference between
pixels and dips and SPS and all those
different things in density read this
blog post it's a fairly good primer that
we also have good documentation on it
but this may be you know a simpler way
of looking at things
and that was by Edwin Evans who I've
never heard it before but thanks admin
for the awesome blog post alright so
that's a that's it for this week on
Android design in action thanks for
tuning in and sorry we ran a little bit
late fortunately had unfortunately we
had too much content it's always a good
problem to have a right to much come we
just talk too much okay well anyway
thanks again for joining as always I'm
Roman Eric Adam coach Nick butcher see
you guys next week see you guys right